we heard some from anne-marie trevelli
in there about what is happening in
westminster i mean what is going on with
some of these parliamentarians that this
behavior is still going on uh for all
this time
well i want to begin by apologizing for
my i.t problems here in the uh
uh you think we'd have all mastered it
by now but to come to your question
uh i think it's been a bad week for
politics uh
you know these things seem
out of time
and women today whether it's in politics
or journalism or any other
workplace
are clearly not going to put up with
the kind of language and behavior that
we've seen this week although we might
have seen years and decades ago and if i
had one conclusion from the whole thing
it's that all of this just seems out of
time with the age we're living in it's
2022 it's not
some time
decades ago so these behaviors do no
good for politics and and that matters
because
this is the arena whereby the nation has
to work out its problems that's what
politics is for well that's
on the cost of living crisis or attitude
to the war in ukraine or any other major
question
i mean uh you've been in uh parliament
now since about 2005. it's quite a long
run there have you seen inappropriate
behavior
in the house of parliament
i personally haven't of course you know
these reports are there for
for all to see
and people are there we're there to
represent our constituents we're there
to do
uh the best job we can
and
i still think despite all the
awful reports of
things that we've seen over the past few
days most people who come into politics
do it for good reasons they do it for
public service they do it because they
want to serve their country and serve
their constituents
and that's really important as i say
because
if we conclude from all this but it's
all simply a nest of rogues and bullies
and you know maybe even worse then
that's really bad for our democracy so
we're not asking for
sainthood in politics but we are asking
for proper professional behavior and
some of the instances that we've seen
over the past week clearly fall short of
that standard i mean there are some
rules of course in place and there are
procedures to deal with this sort of
thing are they just simply
not strong enough
well i think your viewers will feel
we've heard all this before about rules
and procedures and they have been
changed in recent years and
you know i believe that the speaker is
serious about this and making it a good
place and a safe place for people to
work and a place where people can raise
things but
it doesn't look so far
like the changes of recent years have
fully dealt with the problem
if it had then you wouldn't be seeing
the reports that we've seen over the
past week
okay let's just move on slightly if we
can you will have seen some of the
reporting for the past
day or so about the leader of your party
uh sakia stammer and those allegations
that he uh broke lockdown rules up in
durham i mean
no
equivalence with what's happened in
downtreat and whitehall of course but if
mr summer is found to have broken the
rules and is fine should he resign
well the police have already looked at
this and done them and they've they've
found nothing to
to take action on and um you know people
are trying to draw some equivalence to
this
but the police have already looked at it
and that's been their conclusion and i
simply don't believe
that
this is equivalent in any way to a
series of parties bring your own booze
boo's been brought in by the suitcase
with abba singing winner takes all in
the background
and the attempt to draw equivalence is
to
is to try to it's always you know
they want people to think
everybody it's all the same so no
scandal matters uh and that's a bad
place for this i'm not sorry i i did
make it very clear i'm not trying to
draw an equivalence at all what i'm
simply saying is that the labour party
have said that boris johnson and rich
should resign if they're found to have
broken the rules and they've been fined
i'm saying that if it does transpire
that secure stamina or anger or anyone
else for that matter the labor party has
broken the rules and is fined should
they resign well that situation hasn't
arisen because the durham police have
looked at this and found that no rules
were broken so
uh that doesn't arise in this case
and if it did just finally
well but it hasn't and it doesn't okay
you refuse
fine refuse to go on that i perfectly
understand let's move on a little bit if
we can then to uh the situation that the
country is facing you will have of
course seen uh reporting that the
chancellor of the exchequer is
suggesting now a windfall tax be brought
in um that's something the labour party
have been calling for hasn't it
uh yes it is something we've been
calling for and for good reason the cost
of living crisis is really hurting
families we've called for this for
about four months now in order to get
extra help particularly to people in the
lowest incomes with these rocketing
energy bills and today is the first day
that people will see the tory tax rises
in their payslips as well as we come to
the end of april
and the chancellor has so far
steadfastly ruled out taking this action
i hope he does reconsider and if he does
it will be
an admission that the spring statement
that he gave a few weeks ago
fell far short of the scale of the
challenge and the scale of help that
people need
i mean apart from the windfall tax what
else would be done obviously this energy
crisis is continuing
on is there anything different that the
labour party would be doing to try and
deal with the cost of living crisis well
apart from the windfall tax we have
called for
uh the elimination of vat on energy
bills which is something that uh the
prime minister and many people who
supported brexit said would be one of
the earliest uh benefits of brexit well
we've got brexit now and now they've
changed their mind and they don't want
to do this so that's also something that
could take
money off bills
and
in terms of the tax rises that are
coming in now we've also said what is
the point
of being the only country in the g7
to ask working people to pay more income
taxes this year
only to promise to reduce them in two
years time taxation should be about the
needs of public services not the timing
of the tory election campaign plan and
that's what the chancellor's doing with
this hoki koki act on income tax so
there's a number of things that could be
done that would get real help to people
with this cost of living crisis right
now
and just a final thought then we found
and on the news this morning they were
reporting that um two brits seem to have
been taken by russian forces in ukraine
i mean what should be done to try and
get those people back and what message
do you think they should be for any
britons who are still in ukraine should
they all just return home now
well i understand that the foreign
office will do everything they can for
any british person uh captured
abroad uh we've seen with the visit of
the un secretary general yesterday
to ukraine where the russians actually
shelled the capital while he was there
the contempt that russia is showing for
the united nations right now
we've got to stand strong against that
do what we can to help ukraine
a country which is engaged in a an
existential fight for its own freedom
and its right to decide its own future
and for all the divisions in politics we
are right behind all our allies in
trying to do that